las desigualdades de género se trasladan
hasta la jubilación en Francia según
muchos expertos las mujeres serán de las
más vulneradas por la reforma que busca
el gobierno del presidente Emmanuel
mahou pues son las que toman permisos
para entales más largos y trabajar a
tiempo parcial con más frecuencia que
los hombres
Maggie López es enfermera participó en
las manifestaciones contra la reforma
fue la
tenía un horario a tiempo parcial y en
algún momento pedí una baja por
maternidad en otro momento de mi carrera
me tomé un año sabático porque realmente
necesitaba un descanso y como
consecuencia de todo ello me veo en la
necesidad de cotizar al sistema de
pensiones durante más tiempo
el gobierno quiere retrasar la edad de
jubilación dos años hasta los 64 sobre
todo porque el número de jubilados es
superior al de los trabajadores que
cotizan muchos investigadores denuncian
también el impacto de la Reforma en las
mujeres
constituidos
en Francia que cotizar 42 años ahora y
pronto serán 43 años en 2027
y los permisos de las mujeres para
cuidar a los niños actualmente se
compensan en parte y va a mejorar un
poco la compensación pero no está el
punto de igualar los dos años más que se
pide a muchas de estas mujeres
los datos del gobierno muestran que las
pensiones de las mujeres francesas son
un 40% inferiores a las de los hombres